for a long time we may cope well enough
we make it to work every morning we give
pleasant summaries of our lives to
friends
we smile over dinner we aren't totally
balanced
but there's little way of knowing how
difficult things might be for other
people
and what we have a right to expect in
terms of contentment and peace of mind
we probably tell ourselves to stop being
self-indulgent
and redouble our efforts to feel worthy
through achievement
we are probably world experts in not
feeling sorry for ourselves
decades may pass it's not uncommon for
the most serious mental conditions to
remain undiagnosed for half a lifetime
we simply don't notice that we are
beneath the surface
chronically anxious filled with
self-loathing and close to overwhelming
despair and rage
this too simply ends up feeling normal
until one day
finally something triggers a collapse it
might be a crisis at work
a reversal in our career plans or a
mistake we've made over a task
it might be a romantic failure someone
leaving us or a realization that we are
profoundly unhappy with a partner we had
thought might be our long-term future
alternatively we feel mysteriously
exhausted and sad
to the extent that we can't face
anything anymore even a family meal or a
conversation with a friend
or we are struck by unmanageable anxiety
around everyday challenges
like addressing our colleagues or going
into a shop
we're swamped by a sense of doom and
imminent catastrophe
we sob uncontrollably we are in a mental
crisis and if we are lucky we will know
to put up the white flag at once
there is nothing shameful or rare in our
condition
we have fallen ill as so many before us
have
we need not compound our sickness with a
sense of embarrassment
this is what happens when one is a
delicate human facing the hurtful
alarming and always uncertain conditions
of existence
recovery can start the moment one admits
one no longer has a clue how to cope
the roots of the crisis almost certainly
go a long way back
things will not have been right in
certain areas for an age
possibly forever there will have been
grave inadequacies in the early days
things that were said and done to us
that should never have occurred
and bits of reassurance and care that
were ominously missed out on
on top of this adult life will have
layered on difficulties which we were
not well equipped to know how to endure
it will have applied pressure along our
most tender invisible fault lines
our illness is trying to draw attention
to our problems
but it can only do so inarticulately by
throwing up coarse and vague symptoms
it knows how to declare that we are
worried and sad but it can't tell us
what about and why
that will be the work of patient
investigation over months and years
probably in the company of experts the
illness contains the cure
but it has to be teased out and its
original inarticulate interpreted
something from the past is crying out to
be recognized
and will not leave us alone until we
have given it its due
it may seem at points like a death
sentence
but we are beneath the crisis being
given an opportunity to restart our
lives on a more generous
kind and realistic footing there is an
art to being ill
and to daring at last to listen to what
our pain
is trying to tell us our emotional first
aid kit provides a set of useful salves
to some of life's most
challenging psychological situations
including friendship love sex work
and self click the link on screen now to
find out more